من جهتها نقلت صحيفتها اريتس عن مسؤول في
حزب المعسكر الذي يقوده بيني جانس قوله ان
الحزب سينسحب من حكومه الطوارئ
الاسرائيليه اذا توصل الى انطباع بان
نتنياهو يرفض صفقه التبادل الاسرى
لاعتبارات سياسيه او اذا اعلن نتنياهو عن
حكم عسكري في
غزه معنا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره امين
درغامي امين اذا بين اللاءات الثلاث
لنتنياهو وخشيته من انهيار الحكومه كيف
يتطور المشهد في
اسرائيل في الحقيقه سهام الهو بين ا دوائر
الحكم هنا في اسرائيل من خلال او حول هذه
الصفقه تزداد هذه الهوه
وتبدو وتظهر المزيد من الخلافات في حكومه
بنيامين
نتنياهو طبعا كل ذلك يضع وفق مراقبين
نتنياهو في مازق حقيقي فهو من جهه يخشى من
وزراء اقصى اليمين في حكومته ومن جهه اخرى
يريد او يخضع لضغوط الدول الغربيه وخاصه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ل تنفيذ هذه
الصفقه والموافقه عليها في تفاصيل
التسريبات
التي ظهرت تباعا بخصوص ما جرى في جلسه
المجلس الوزاري المصغر للشؤون السياسيه
والامنيه الليله قبل الماضيه في مبنى
وزاره الدفاع نتنياهو في هذه الجلسه شدد
على الخطوط الحمراء الثلاثه التي كان قد
اعلن عنها في وقت سابق ولطالما كرر
التاكيد عليها وهي رفضه وقف الحرب
وا سحب القوات قوات الجيش من قطاع غزه
وايضا الافراج عن الاف الاسرى الفلسطينيين
كل ذلك دفع بعدد من الوزراء خاصه من حزب
المعسكر
الرسمي وفق طبعا تسريبات من ذلك الاجتماع
بانهم ايضا هددوا بالانسحاب من الحكومه
وقالوا بانهم اذا ما كان لديهم اي انطباع
بان نتنياهو يحاول افشال هذه الصفقه
لاعتبارات سياسيه ضيقه او اذا كان نتنياهو
يسعى الى اقامه حكم عس في قطاع غزه فان ح
وزراء هذا الحزب الذي يقوده طبعا بيني
جينس سينسحبون ايضا من هذه الحكومه وهو ما
دفع نتنياهو خلال هذه الجلسه ايضا الى
مطالبه جميع الوزراء بعدم الانسحاب من هذه
الحكومه كانت عباره عن مناشده لل الوزراء
الذين كانوا يجتمعون وقال لهم
بان بقائهم في هذه الحكومه يعطي قوه طبعا
ل مواصله عملها في هذا الشان وايضا تكمن
قوه اسرائيل بحسب تعبيره وبحسب طبعا هذه
التسريبات في وحدتها كل ذلك
طبعا قبل يعني جوله سيقوم بها وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي الى المنطقه من بينها
طبعا سعوديه قطر مصر وايضا اسرائيل والضفه
الغربيه هناك من يرى بان نتنياهو يحاول
قبل هذا اللقاء الذي من المرتقب ان يجمعه
ب بلينكن ان يحاول ان يقرب على الاقل
وجهات النظر بخصوص هذه الصفقه خاصه وان
هناك رفض لعدد من النقاط خاصه تلك
المتعلقه بان تشمل او يشمل وقف اطلاق
النار مده تزيد عن شهر وايضا هناك معارضه
شديده لمساله اطلاق عدد كبير من
الاسرى الفلسطينيين و وهو ما يضع نتنياهو
وفق مراقبين في مازق حقيقي ويهدد حكومته
خاصه وان هناك تهديدات بدت جديه هذه المره
خاصه من اقصى اليمين المتطرف الحديث هنا
عن بيتسل سموتريتش وايضا اطمار بنفير
الذان طبعا
يعدان حلفاء له في هذه الحكومه من
الانسحاب اذا ما كانت اي صفقه وافقت عليها
حكومه نتنياهو تعطي حصانه لحركه حماس او
تؤدي في النهايه الى الافراج عن عدد كبير
من الاسرى الفلسطينيين وسط ذلك يزداد ايضا
الضغط من
عائلات الاسرى والمحتجزين الاسرائيليين في
قطاع غزه اليوم من المنتظر ان تكون هناك
مظاهرات لعائلات الاسرى في اطار طبعا
زياده هذا الضغط وهناك ايضا انتقادات من
كانت قد صدرت قبل يومين بالتحديد من اعضاء
في الوفد الا اسرائيلي الذي يشارك في هذه
المفاوضات بخصوص صفقه تبادل الاسرى والذي
انتقد تصريحات نتنياهو خلال اجتماعه
بعائلات هؤلاء الاسرى والمحتجزين
الاسرائيليين والذي قال بان اي صفقه لن
تكون دون ثمن واعتبروا بان مثل هذه
التصريحات يمكن في النهايه ان تؤدي سهام
الى الحاق ضرر بسير هذه المفاوضات وشككوا
بان نتنياهو بالفعل يحاول ويسعى لافشال
هذه الصفقه شكرا لك درغامي مراسل الجزيره
كنت معنا من تل ابيب